los antebrazos contienen músculos
flexores que le permiten doblar los
dedos
estructuras largas en forma de cordón
llamadas tendones conectan estos
músculos con los huesos de los dedos y
El pulgar un túnel de tejido llamado
vaina del tendón rodea cada tendón esto
permite que el tendón se deslice
suavemente cuando los dedos se mueven
la vaina se mantiene en su lugar
mediante bandas de tejido llamadas
poleas estas mantienen el tendón cerca
del hueso para que tenga un
funcionamiento óptimo
cuando los músculos flexores se contraen
las poleas ayudan a guiar a los tendones
para flexionar o doblar los dedos
normalmente los tendones se deslizan
suavemente a través de las poleas cuando
los dedos se flexionan y se extienden el
dedo en gatillo También conocido como
pulgar en gatillo o tenosinovitis
estenosante es una afección en la cual
la polea en la base del dedo se inflama
y se hincha
esto dificulta que el tendón se mueva a
través de la polea
con el tiempo el tendón también puede
hincharse y formar una protuberancia
cerca de la polea cuando se dobla el
dedo el área inflamada en el tendón
puede causar una sensación de enganche o
gatillo ya que inicialmente se engancha
en la polea y luego se desliza por
debajo
si no se trata el tendón puede hincharse
lo suficiente como para que no pueda
pasar por debajo de la polea como
resultado el dedo puede quedar atascado
en una posición doblada
si tiene un dedo en gatillo puede tener
uno o más de los siguientes síntomas un
bulto blando en la palma de la mano en
la base de su dedo una sensación de
enganche traba o bloqueo cuando mueve el
dedo y dolor al doblar o estirar el dedo
no se conoce la causa del dedo en
gatillo sin embargo algunas afecciones
que pueden aumentar el riesgo incluyen
diabetes
artritis reumatoide gota y lesiones
repetidas el agarre fuerte y repetitivo
de la mano también puede aumentar el
riesgo
para tratar el dedo en gatillo leve el
médico puede recomendarle que descanse
la mano y evite las actividades que lo
empeoren
el médico puede recetarle medicamentos
antiinflamatorios o una inyección de
corticosteroides para reducir la
inflamación
[Música]
también es posible que necesite usar una
férula para mantener el dedo recto
si los tratamientos no quirúrgicos no
han funcionado el médico puede
recomendarle que se someta a un
procedimiento quirúrgico para iniciar el
procedimiento el cirujano hace una
pequeña incisión en la palma de la mano
luego se corta la polea para liberar el
tendón
al final del procedimiento la incisión
se puede cerrar con puntos y se cubre
con un vendaje suave
para obtener más información sobre el
dedo en gatillo hable con su médico